it's a play Capcom exclusive yahwah's
Ready Set Radio manpower 98.3 bootleg
Kevin studio with a legend right now man
you're no man we have got the homey man
representing Shaolin we got the homey
Raekwon in the building what's happening
what's happening captain the chef is
here was good BK man I'd be way to
interview for a minute brother respect
man I've interviewed over the phone
before when I only built 4 Cuban Linx
two drops okay you know it's cool to
find n equal to in person man no it's
all good man Congrats over the last like
three four years you just like being
killing him and the long-awaited you
know sequel to the classic came out
didn't disappoint yeah you was neck and
neck on iTunes with hold the year you
dream I remember that week it came out
yeah yeah yeah I mean you know this is
what I love to do this is my sport you
know what I mean I I try to do it to my
best ability you know me and to be
honest with you II don't feel like as
long as it been in my career you know
we've been down for 20 years so it's
like 20 years man I still feel like in
reality I might have got six in right
you know what I mean so I'm still
working on I feel like um over the last
couple years you've been working like
almost like a new artist you've been
putting out so much butter you point out
mixtapes yeah a couple albums I mean
yeah is there is there a reason why I
feel like you and ghosts specifically
out of the Klan are just so active and
we always you know always fans like
myself are always you know we always
have something to quench our wu-tang or
our Raekwon you know yeah you know I
guess you know for me man all I could do
is is continue the legacy one way or
another you know on a man it's like when
you're dealing with a nine man group
everybody's not gonna be the hot boy you
know anything so you know it's just
really all about who's out there doing
what they supposed to do you know what I
mean and you know a lot of guys made a
lot of money too you know it's you know
for me it's like I can never be
satisfied I'm
a lot of money um you know I live a
certain kind of lifestyle but I'm still
grounded and you know I gotta keep
continuing to do my best thing and pay
and pay my bills and you know I mean
make sure everything is good so I'm out
there like that you know at me other
dudes I don't I can't tell what they
doing you know what I mean all I can do
is just look at what I do you know I
just saw that you were in the studio
with Jay right I saw you post that man s
feel like like it's been a long time
coming like you say yeah well how did
you guys get in the lab I mean what's up
with that now we just chillin you know I
mean I can't really talk about it like
that you know that secret is definitely
top secret you know music I mean you
know yeah y'all go and see which I see
when y'all see it I think no we just yes
but you know we can't we can't tell you
what its gonna be into what its gonna be
you know I'm like what like the mutual
respect between you and hope man like I
feel like there's very few artists that
I mean you of course were doing your
thing before whole like you know before
whole really got poppin you know what
I'm saying but I feel like from New York
there's like a handful of dudes who have
been consistent and you know you know
kept that that quality and and that
level of music up to a certain standard
I feel like you know it's a small club
you know when you guys talk man I mean
is it is there is does he have that same
respect for you that I'm sure you have
for him I mean it's like two bosses
linking up oh absolutely you know what I
mean like you know it was more just you
know a great introduction you know what
I mean because I've never really seen
them like that you guys never yeah you
know of course you've not seen them in
on seen him in different parts of the
world once or twice though but we was
both on the move right we never got a
chance to sit down and really rap you
know it was just us you know what I mean
and you know we just laugh and talk
about life talking about children
talking about you know the future of of
the game where we look at it the at
being you know to me but it was just a
random random conversation man we were
so he wasn't even talk the conversation
it's probably way overdue yeah just you
know sometimes man is just about
you know seeing seeing artists at its
best you know what I mean and and seeing
one of your favorite artists at its best
you know what I mean
like you know two to three years like
you said we might have came a little bit
before but you know I respect hot we
went with it you know he took it
somewhere where you know it ain't a lot
of rappers that did that back then you
know what I mean in the game that period
like I'm talking about from even when
you know the Run DMC era you know of
course catch was getting money hear that
you know what I mean but what this dude
is done it's like wow you know what I
mean and you know I was definitely just
commemorating the morning at like yo I'm
not only a fan but I respect how you you
moving you know what I mean you're
moving real you're moving like a leader
supposed to move you know and on we just
cracking up laughing talking about kids
you know family aunts you know what I
mean like just life man just just life
man you know that's what home whatever
is gonna happen he's got some needs that
yeah you know what I mean like you know
of course it's business but more
importantly you know what I mean y'all
y'all gonna see what it do you know
we'll see you of course work with yay
mm-hmm he actually today I saw right
before I came over here that he
announced his new album is called yeezus
what what do you think of the title I
just want to get you reactions you know
that's that's ill cuz cuz you know me I
look at titles as as a reflection of
your mind on where he was at making that
up right you know what I mean and all
that's serious that's really serious
that's interesting and you know I went I
know him you know what I mean he has a
he has a strong personality when it
comes to accomplishing things you know
what I mean so if he made the album
yeezus I mean well you know that's the
name of it I mean if he made it yeah
it's gonna be strong he's gonna be some
strong [__] how did you and Kanye link
up man cuz you know I was one of them
I'm a super hip-hop head you know like
my you know nas nas mooting when I was a
kid you know what was what I listened to
you yeah he's like you know Ben
to me the most consistent artists like
one I mean top three ever like to do you
know to me his catalog is untouchable
absolutely I agree and when I saw that
you were on the album I got really
excited I was like I asked the song I
want to hear
did you guys link up um you know to
mutual friends mutual business partners
you know um I just got the call one day
you know what I mean but it you know
it's like you know you see guys in the
business you see man yo we talk for a
second but everybody's just so so moving
around yeah but when I you know when we
finally connected it was the phone call
that they call to say yo he wants you on
the joint so you know of course
automatically we talk you know what I
mean I was excited he was excited and
then it was just basically yo I love I
love this music man I love I love what
you guys crunch to the table you know
what I mean like you know like sometimes
a lot of people look at us as favorite
rappers favorite rapper you know I mean
a lot of title you know what I mean it's
like being a Michael Jordan in the sport
so you know I love it and you know like
I said it was just genuine man it was
like girl whatever man let's do it you
know I'm a vile person to like I go all
for that as well
you know what I mean it ain't so much
about the artists from from a growing
perspective of he's rich and he you know
I mean I do it with [__] that's broke
too you know I'm saying I pawned me for
cursing boners okay quite on you know
I'm a normal guy I'm a normal guy in you
know the fellas was mutual it was great
and we came up with something strong you
know um made it made it made it a
classic piece after 20 years like you
just said you love the music you arts it
like the most active oh you know member
of wu-tang you know I'm saying and I
almost look at like you you and ghost to
me are the two artists that like if I
had to pick the ghost face catalog and
the Raekwon catalog over the wu-tang
catalog I would take either y'all's over
Woo's catalog and you know that's saying
a lot cuz y'all got [__] oh it's a group
of you and ghost
y'all got like classics
see that's see I know you saying that
because
you like you like lyrics - yeah Patel
you know what I mean like you know a lot
of people look at will Chang for
different personality reasons as well of
course and I'm of course mean stalks we
just sprouted like the youngest think is
out of everybody in the team we probably
still got that kid in us when we say all
kind of crazy [__] and you know it just
gets to the point where it's like yo you
know you come up with words and
different philosophies and you know
different production like we still faint
out to that I mean I want to ask me that
is one years like the passion for this
hip-hop music you know what I'm saying
like how do you like I just how is it
not like you know gotten old already cuz
you are still killing [__] you're still
doing what you doing like I'm still
excited about the music it's just it's
just I love the job man I love the job
some people you know they love what they
do you know what I mean you got you got
you know people that pay attention today
they sport of what they love you know
what I mean to me that's just me keeping
it on it is like I love it you know what
I mean I'm a kid that never you know I
come from a broken dream spot broken
dreams all through the block you know so
when I had a opportunity to change my
life it was like wrong with it you know
what I mean one would it appreciate it
treat people how you want to be treated
yeah and get into it you know what I
mean be successful in and that's what
that was always my thing and I still
feel like that to this day like you know
if I get the right production in my hand
you know and or the right team the right
team of people to join forces with me
the way I supposed to it's like going
I'm gonna be here another 10 years
because you know what I mean that's how
I feel and to be fair I think the fact
that you've linked up with 2 Chainz with
Rick Ross on records yeah I feel like
you like probably got new fans off of
those records that like know exactly
exactly and you know for me that's
that's that's a part of the politic move
you know what I mean is the definitely
you know tap into the younger generation
but I like I'm a fan - yeah you know
what I mean I give it up when it's time
to give it up and the music is where
need to be I'm a
man you know what I mean straight up so
I love music you know what I mean like I
said of all kinds of music to not just
write you know let me hip hop like I
like reggae you know I like I like rock
music you don't of me you know I'm just
universal if I like some soul music you
know that's the [__] I'm gonna call
constantly playing the slow money dry so
you know cuz I'm thinking about a lot of
things it's registering right now um
let's talk about rock the bells man they
had this big announcement of course it
was last week
yeah you guys I feel like you guys are
doing Rock the Bells even NAS I want to
say like I feel like every time I go to
Rocko bells either you and ghost are
performing together you know it's always
some ooh tang you know represented that
rock the bells but there
the big news is you know ODB is gonna be
there's a virtual performance right
can you kind of like shine some light on
that how you feel about it I mean what
can we expect I'm gonna keep it a
million with you it's like I have this
much knowledge of everything you know um
you know of course rize's the you know
he's the home he's the train conductor
right you know you know all I could do
is just wait so I get the call from my
on my team and they tell me what's going
on you know it's gonna be I assume it's
gonna happen during the wu-tang
performance it got to I mean if that's
what it is you know I mean like like I
said I can't really jump out the window
and say if it's a goal if it's not a
goal or however it's gonna go because it
wasn't it wasn't sat down and talked to
with me are you I mean I mean how like
are you are you looking forward to to to
the potential of you know what it could
be of course I mean you know like I said
do you know what I mean that's that's my
brother I wish he was here right now
well you know what I mean but you know
that's something that I think the family
got a you know um August rate you
dealing with stuff like that you have to
you have to go through the family you
can't just throw it up there because you
know you never know how the family may
say that yeah you know I mean so you
know hopefully they'll get all that
worked out yeah that's something I
really want to see me yeah that's dope
you know what I mean I mean che not
gonna worry if I had that you know do it
for me
yeah you don't I mean because we married
to the game this you know we love the
music we love the fans we love the
people that that's checking for us
through thick and thin regardless of
whatever it is so you know I pray I pray
it works out one of my favorite
up-and-coming dudes is Action Bronson
right and a smart guy first heard action
brought us my dive yo what's up with
this new ghost face is so cold
yeah super cold any-any represents you
know what I mean that five boroughs to
the fullest you know nummy like I said I
died between to meet him early like when
he was just coming here and you know
like you say yo you sound like my
brother you sound like go solo song even
to me and you know I always feel like
nobody can't really sound too much like
us like yeah yeah yeah yeah ghost got
that he got that that voice that that
slither that you know what I mean and
Bronson he talk like that so he's not
even trying to be something that he's
not he really talks like that you know
what I mean so um he was just kicking it
man he just mad cool we did some things
you know what I mean you might hand me
on his record as well yeah and he's
rhyming I'm talking about now to me the
and I know you paying attention to the
news I can't answer it said you to it he
sounded like ghost no more I agree I
think he's mean and I'm not saying it
like he ever sounded let me say it
exactly like when he got his